young people's greatest aspiration is
not to be an astronaut but it's to be a
YouTuber but in your Deep dive
conversation with Andrew Tate he
mentioned about the harmful nature of
social media what is The Good the Bad
and the Ugly of social media
historically people have done a lot to
get 15 seconds of Fame that feeling is a
form of a hive sometimes being so
concerned about eyeballs forces you to
put eyeballs over what you stand for
where it's recognition more than True
Values and principles if you can manage
that and still stay true to your
character and your values and principles
and not compromise that no matter how
many eyeballs you get good for you